right-wing extremists already have a
plan to literally steal the next
presidential election and they're not
making a secret of it
I'm Dave Rubin this is the Reuben report
it is February 1st 2023 as always we are
live streaming on Rumble YouTube and
locals subscribe if you have not and of
course we've got the post game wrap-up
show exclusive for our locals memories
you can join us at rubenboard.locals.com
I cannot believe it is February 1st is
this is time just going faster am I just
getting old 46 years old middle age
things just start speeding up is it
something about having kids I don't know
what it is but the days seem to be
getting shorter the months are flying by
like it really is just nuts I think it
has something to do with kovid maybe
people working at home more science just
getting faster and faster and faster and
faster
but on this show we pack it in a lot of
information and we're going to have a
dense program for you today before we
get to it though I do have to apologize
for something because
you know yesterday uh I called Kathy
hokel and of course Kathy is the the
governor of New York she was appointed
Governor after Andrew Cuomo stepped down
and then she locked down the state and
forced people to be injected and fired
uh doctors and nurses for not being
vaccinated and all that stuff but then
she did get reelected and you got to
give credit where credit is due she won
by Five Points she is the governor of
New York and yesterday we were doing a
little uh bit on her we showed some
video and when we came back from the
video a phrase was in my mind and I had
to say it I I knew it was probably going
to get us demonetized or I was going to
get some hate for it but I called her
the botoxed
and uh then we thought about it after
the show and some of you there she is
there she is the the botox that's
what I called her and uh you know some
people were upset about that and I do
want to actually issue an apology we're
in a time where people issue apologies
and I want to apologize
to all I want to apologize to
female dogs because there are so many
great female dogs out there this is our
old dog Emma you guys may remember Emma
she was a wonderful dog that that
picture on the right over there that's
Emma when we adopted her she was a
rescue from Hurricane Katrina in New
Orleans she was about a year or a year
and a half old at that point uh that
picture top left was she had about a
year left she was about 15 years old in
La uh and that picture at the bottom
there with the two dogs that is Emma
just a month or so before she passed
away at the ripe old age of 16 we
reconnected her with one of her three
puppies from New Orleans because I had
tweeted a picture about her before she
passed away when we knew she was sick
and it turned out that her son Bernard
the brown guy over there who he was an
Old Timer too he was like 14 at that
point uh he lived in La too and we got
them together after not seeing each
other for about 14 years and I follow
Bernard's owner on Instagram now Bernard
is 18 he's still alive and then that
picture of her looking like a little
rocket ship jumping off the deck there
that was like two days before we had to
put her down you know she was on
steroids and we were trying to do
everything we can and probably held on a
little bit too long which is one of the
toughest things you do in life is when
you have to say goodbye to a pet and she
was like jazzed up on steroids and she
flew like a little look at that she
looks like a little bomb just flying off
the deck like that so I really do want
to apologize to all female dogs
I want to apologize to anyone who owns a
female dog anyone who you know just has
a love for the the canine I apologize I
should not have compared a female dog
who and these these animals are so loved
actually Daphne just got a dog two days
ago Francesca is the newest member of
the Reuben report family what is she
she's like a pug a French Bulldog she's
a and in no way in no way is a
technically you have to be the
mother to be the like if you're
born and you're immediately a female dog
are you a right off the bat
or you're a later in life
the point is I I don't want to compare
these wonderful animals who've brought
so much joy to so many of us to Kathy
hokel so I apologize to all the dogs out
there thank you for not canceling me
let's do a show okay so the big thing
happening in the last day or so we're
going to shift a little bit from what
we've been doing is that the uh this
Trump DeSantis fight seems to be a bruin
and as I've been saying for months well
first off I do not know I live in
Florida I'm fairly well connected I know
a bunch of people I have no idea if Ron
DeSantis is running for president I I
genuinely have no idea no one on the
inside has given me any inkling
whatsoever you know my whole Florida
crew of people that I bring on the show
all the time nobody has any information
that anyone has passed to me but the way
the whole thing seems to be shaped and
seems to be going the direction of the
river seems to be that DeSantis will run
and it and Trump clearly has announced
already over two months ago at this
point which is not that he is running
for president and you can see as I've
been saying for months that what the
media wants more than anything else is
these two guys to destroy each other if
you're just a member of the media so
you're a Democrat activist because
that's what you are basically if you're
a CNN anchor you know journalist if
you're someone at the New York Times
Washington Post if you're part of the
machine in any way you're part of that
Elite machine what would you want well
you don't want Trump obviously right
Trump was orange Hitler and now you've
got DeSantis who they're just going to
make into as I keep saying Hitler with a
calculator right like because he's
competent so at least for them Trump was
somewhat incompetent but now they're
going to make DeSantis seem even worse
because he's getting so many things done
and we're going to get into a whole
bunch of those things in just a bit so
what would you want more than anything
else you would want these guys to
destroy each other now let me say that I
think political fighting
between candidates sometimes it can
really sharpen the candidates and make
them better let's not forget that when
Barack Obama was running the first time
uh there was another candidate a lady
that some of you may have heard of named
Hillary Clinton who was the presumptive
nominee and uh they were extremely split
and it got pretty nasty and Hillary did
a whole bunch of nasty things she's
known to do some nasty things don't kill
me Hillary
um so but it probably made Obama a
better candidate now unfortunately his
presidency didn't turn out all that
great and I regret voting for him and I
should be judged accordingly
um but nobody's perfect okay but the
point is having some level of a fight is
good however
when you have a fight on the Democrat
side the machine is operating the entire
time to make sure nobody's too wounded
because that's who they want to get
through right so the machine didn't want
to demolish Hillary and it didn't want
to demolish Obama because it wants
Democrats in power Democrats are for
bigger government Democrats are for
taking more of your money they're for
more of the superstructure to control
your life so that's what the machine
wants in a case of the Republicans well
we know what the machine feels about
Trump even though Trump is the number
one guy to get the machine clicks and
Views and everything else but they've
made their feelings about him very clear
and we had couple sham impeachments and
this nonsenseical January 6th and the
raid at Mar-A-Lago and all of these
ridiculous things and the lawsuits in
New York all the stuff that turns into
nothing right now you've got this guy
DeSantis who's doing literally
everything right in Florida and the
proof is in the pudding because he just
won by 20 points which is the most
Floridian Governor has ever won by and
and this place is absolutely flourishing
as I mentioned yesterday 2.5 percent
unemployment remarkably low we're
rebuilding Bridges and Roads and houses
super fast we're getting 1200 new
Floridians every single day et cetera et
cetera so you don't have to look at all
the policies and be like is this a good
policy or bad policy at the end of the
day you can just look at where people
are going where do they go where do they
go to move where do they go to vacation
where do they go to spend their money
etc etc okay
so what does this all lead us to what it
leads us to is there is a fight Brewing
the media is going to push it and what I
think we have to focus on is it's
probably two things one is not giving
the media exactly what it wants not
going after regardless of what side
you're on of this obviously uh I'm a big
DeSantis guy I like Trump a lot too I
like him personally I like his kids I
voted for the guy there's certainly a
situation which I'm going to vote for
him again absolutely all of those things
but we don't want to fall for the traps
when they're trying to make sure that
they destroy each other because the last
thing you want
because it's particularly Disney I just
I would be such a good candidate you
don't want him irreparably wounded by
the time you get to the to the general
election right so the other part of that
is you don't want to fall for the media
traps but also what you want to do is
make room for the people that might vote
Republican for the first time and
there's a whole bunch of these people
right you could even look at someone
like me who finally for the first time
in my life as a Floridian I'm now a
registered Republican okay there's
plenty of people in that disaffected
liberal space and Ron DeSantis happens
to be liked by those people Elon Musk
right he was loved by the left his whole
life now he's thought of as far right
said he would support DeSantis and even
Bill Martin I'm not going to do too much
more stuff here I promise
um but you may remember this from a
couple months ago Bill Maher defending
Governor DeSantis and basically saying
that he should run for president I mean
yeah I understand what you're saying
about the Senate the reason and why I
think DeSantis is so strong is because
he can do both things he can do the
performance art that seems to have you
so exercise to the base most of which I
don't really know if it's that damaging
he picks a fight with Disney does it
really affect anybody I mean I read the
don't say gay which is not the name of
the law they called it the don't say
Gala it could have been called the let's
do things in schools the way we did five
years ago law
so what I'm saying is he can do both
that but he yes he he knows how to rile
up the base I agree he's a politician
but he also can be a normal governor in
other words after the storm he can stand
with President Biden
like a normal Governor does and work
with them and then send some migrants to
Martha's vision
you know and that's a very powerful
thing to have both those elements it
will definitely beat Trump again would
he be DeSantis that I don't know and
it's going to look weird because he will
be like literally twice as old as him
and just no really and the scientist has
like three little kids you know that
always plays well in America likes new
it really likes strange we want some
strange you know you said DeSantis
shouldn't run just Santa should run now
and quickly this is the problem Chris
Christie right he couldn't run in 2011
2012. sometimes in politics you have one
chance okay I don't want to bludgeon you
with the is Bill Maher going to vote
Republican thing that's not why I showed
you that I am going to continue to work
on you Bill for in case you're watching
the show today and I saw you a couple
days ago and I told you I'm going to
keep working on you but I don't want to
make this about Bill what I want to make
this about is the sliver of people in
America who can move when it comes to
voting for president because we know the
hardcore Dems won't move the hard core
Republicans won't move it's how it is
it's that it's the independence it's the
moderates and it's the disaffected
liberals who are breaking it is the same
liberals and there used to be same
liberals who might actually change and I
think all of them in essence would vote
for DeSantis and they wouldn't vote for
Trump that that's just
I think that's just an obvious fact we
sort of know how high Trump can get if
we're to believe that the last election
was legit right Biden got 81 million
votes which sounds insane because he
didn't even campaign and there were no
rallies and nobody really loved him and
the base hated him because he wasn't
Lefty enough but okay again if we're
supposed to believe this any of this
makes sense Biden got 81 million votes
Trump got 75. how does Trump get more
who who are the new people that Trump
could bring in there's probably a whole
bunch of people that Trump has lost
right because he's not as seasoned at
the moment I think it's it's it feel it
doesn't feel like it has the same energy
the world seems to have moved on a
little bit some of that is unjust by the
way by them kicking him off uh Twitter
and and blaming him for January 6 and
all of those things so that's not again
that's not even an attack on Trump I
think this is just a reality I think the
other problem that Trump has is that by
Trump voting by Trump running you're
going to get probably I don't know it
could be five or seven or nine million
people who normally wouldn't even and
vote to just vote because they're voting
anti-trump so these are just realities
that if the Trump campaign is watching
this I think you should address these
realities like how do you negotiate
through these things but the other part
of that is there is going to be this
this sliver of people that will will
never vote for Trump so it's not the
other part it's a continuation of that
right here is Bill Maher who just was
there you just watched him from a few
months ago basically saying DeSantis
should run I also got him on the club
random podcast to say he would move to
Florida if they go for lockdowns again
in Cali you might remember this this was
at the middle of the Trump presidency
which I think most of us would go back
to if we could just go back to 2019
before covet economy chuggings peace
deals in the Middle East just rolling in
every day uh it felt like like things
were good again there was a pride in
America again but look what the Liberals
were saying about Trump and this isn't
necessarily a reflection on Trump I'm
trying to show you the mindset of these
people and you're going to remember this
clip because is Bill Maher in 2019. I
guess they're just going to have to keep
touching this hot stuff I'm not wishing
for a recession but if if the farmers
want to keep touching well you should
wish for a recession because that will
definitely get him unelected okay but
Bill you don't really want a recession I
really do you're gonna we have survived
many recessions we can't survive another
Donald Trump lower middle income
feed him at The Ballot Box in the
intellectual Marketplace so you don't
want to knock those people out of work
but to Tom's point the Tariff I don't
want tariff is actually paid short-term
pain remember everybody yeah
thank you okay so I have no doubt you're
watching that clip and you probably saw
that clip and you're going oh Mar just
said a bunch of sane stuff in the
previous clip and now here's the crazy
stuff right that is crazy to want a
recession because you want to get rid of
the guy the guy who is doing clearly a
far better job uh than the guy that's in
office right now but the guy in office
right now happens to be your guy he's a
blue Democrat Biden when who who in
essence has has wrecked so much of what
Trump had restored to America so again
this isn't about Mar I'm trying to show
you that there is a certain amount of
people that feel that way whether you
think it's legit or not I don't think
it's legit but they do feel that way I
meet them all the time uh you meet them
all the time we know these people so
anyway the the 2024 situation is heating
up and Nikki Haley it is now being sort
of pre-announced that she is going to
make an announcement uh Trump was asked
I think this is from yesterday Trump was
asked about Nikki Haley and Ron DeSantis
here's what he had to say Nikki Haley
called me the other day to talk to me
talk to her for a little while but I
said look you know go buy your heart if
you want to run she's publicly publicly
say that I would run I guess
my president he was a great president
Florida was actually closed for a very
important time remember we close to
beaches and everything else you know
they're trying to rewrite histories okay
so some of this is just political
jockeying it is true that Nikki Haley
said she wasn't going to run against
Trump she did actually say that at one
point but it sounds like she is gonna
run so he is ever he's entitled to say
that but he's been trying one of the
things that you're seeing over the last
48 hours or so is the Trump and the
Trump surrogates are really trying to
make it seem like somehow uh DeSantis
was really for lockdowns and and really
for masks and all of this stuff and it's
like DeSantis actually picked up on it
very quickly and was trying to open up
extremely quickly so when Trump says
that about the beaches and everything
else he might be forgetting Donald Trump
from about two years ago
as many schools and school districts are
closing across the country Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis has not ruled out
uh closing for opening out schools in
May
um saying that many kids are not
vulnerable to this disease do you agree
with that assessment and do you believe
that schools would recommend that
schools open up and to those states that
have well I have a lot of confidence in
Ron DeSantis a lot of faith in Ron
DeSantis to make the right decision he's
doing a great job as Governor Ron
DeSantis I had read where he's thinking
about opening up the schools earlier
than the date the end of the month uh
I'd have to look at the numbers but
again you know I liked so again if
you're a trump person and you're
watching this right the guy that I voted
for I just think this is a losing
strategy DeSantis has become the the
figurehead for fighting covid we are we
are having this policy now he has this
group of people including including
Brett Weinstein and Jay bhattacharya
from Stanford where we are going to look
into vaccine injuries like we've done
more here in Florida on the to stop the
covid madness than anywhere else also
everybody gets a little leash in the
first two months of covid including
Donald Trump by the way I also give
Donald Trump a lot of credit because
Donald Trump from the beginning did not
want to do a federal top-down policy on
covet he was pushing it all to the
States but then and nobody's perfect
when states started opening up Trump did
actually push back you may remember this
this is in April of 2020 from Reuters
U.S president Donald Trump on Wednesday
said he strongly disagrees with George's
aggressive push to reopen its economy in
the midst of the novel coronavirus
pandemic saying it's just too soon to
lift some restrictions Georgia Governor
Brian Kemper Republican and Trump Ally
is allowing businesses such as beauty
salons tattoo parlors and bowling alleys
to reopen as soon as Friday Trump said
Georgia is not adhering to federal
guidelines for states to restart their
economies okay so I'm just trying to
give you a little context because what
do I always do on this show we try to go
to old clips so we don't rewrite history
constantly because if you're rewriting
history constantly you will not get to a
future that is sane because the half
truths that are inherent to rewriting
something will lead you to something
crazy so if you're the Trump people I
just don't think going after DeSantis on
covid is going to make sense at any
level and
I would try another move basically is
what I'm saying uh DeSantis did
yesterday respond to some of these
attacks from Trump
I just well look what I would just say
is this um I roll out of bed I have
people attacking me from all angles it's
been happening for many many years and
if you look at the good thing about it
though is like if you take a crisis
situation like covid you know the good
thing about it is when you're an elected
executive you have to make all kinds of
decisions you got to steer that ship and
the good thing is is that the people are
able to render a judgment on that
whether they reelect you or not and I'm
happy to say you know in my case not
only did we win re-election we won with
the highest percentage of the vote that
any Republican governor candidate has in
the history of the state of Florida
thank you
we won by the largest raw vote margin
over 1.5 million votes than any uh
governor candidate has ever had in
Florida history and in fact we almost
doubled the previous record which I
think was like 780 000 vote margin and
so what I would just say is uh that
verdict has been rendered by the people
of the State of Florida I have to say
one nice thing that DeSantis does he
obviously does a lot of a lot of good
things but one nice thing in his manner
of speaking is you notice how he always
says we we won he doesn't say I that
often and I think that's just I think
that's interesting my guess is it's
probably not too tactical like I think
it's something that's just coming out of
him roughly naturally but when you say
we won meaning it's it's the people that
work for you it's the campaign but it's
we the people who are winning here in
Florida right the proof is in the
pudding we free Floridians are winning
because this guy turned what was a
purple state it was half red half blue
it was flipping this way going that way
we almost had a meth addict as governor
before him all that stuff it is
basically the reddest state in the
nation right now and all of the stuff is
working and we're going to list out a
whole bunch of that stuff right now
because a lot of it is more right wing
than Trump so one of the things that the
scientist is doing is he's calling out
Public Health experts over the George
Floyd protest versus covid protests and
all of the woke lunacy you guys know it
but amazingly we have video
this bizarre but prevalent ideology that
permeates these policy measures
purports to act in the name of justice
for the marginalized but it frowns upon
American institutions it rejects Merit
and achievement and it Advocates
identity essentialism
we reject this woke ideology
we seek normalcy not philosophical
lunacy we will not allow reality facts
and Truth to become optional we will
never surrender to the woke mob Florida
is where woke goes to die
Florida is where woke goes to die
so don't bring any of that crap in this
room okay guys we're not going to
tolerate any of that here because it
dies here uh the messaging is right and
it's not just the messaging it's not
just giving a speech saying what goes to
die here it's killing woke every time it
appears here and it really is working
and it's causing the mainstream media to
go bananas and then he doesn't respond
DeSantis doesn't respond to the
mainstream media and that makes them
even crazier you may remember was it a
New York Times headline what about two
weeks ago where they said you know
Donald Trump used to fight with the
media but DeSantis is worse because he
ignores the media oh my God he ignores
the media I did a slight uh misstep on
the clips here here's the clip now of
DeSantis talking about public health
experts uh what they were saying during
lockdowns in George Floyd uh versus
afterwards they would shame people for
even leaving their house in April May
2020 and you can can't do it some people
wanted to bury loved ones they wanted to
do this and the argument people were
making is well wait a minute I can look
at the risk of covid and it's something
that I'm willing to accept because these
things mean more to me to be able to
bury a loved one or to be able to do
things with my family and and the public
health uh establishment oh no no you
can't make that kind of cost benefit
analysis then
when the George Floyd riots were
happening they actually wrote a letter
with thousands of these people signing
it saying we do not believe that rioting
and protesting is a is bad for covid
that you can do it go ahead because we
think it's so important that you have to
do it and then they said but this
doesn't mean we support all protests if
you're protesting lockdown policies or
other things then you can't do that and
that's when I knew these people are a
bunch of frauds I mean how ridiculous
what's interesting is the last line
there the last two lines that that's
when I knew these people were frauds
because everyone as I always say
everyone gets a leash I give Donald
Trump a leash I would even give Anthony
fauci a little bit of a leash the
beginning of covid maybe not fouchy but
pretty much everybody all the governors
the politicians who were just hit by
this news
and and then had to respond accordingly
and they're being told it's going to
wipe out all of your population and
everything else so is it true that
DeSantis locked down for a bit of course
it is but then as more information came
and as he saw the hypocrisy of the way
they said no no you can go out there and
protest for George Floyd you're not
going to get coveted I mean this was in
essence what they they were literally
articles being written how it's it's for
Public Safety if you're out there
because you're stopping racism so kovid
can kind of be pushed to the side we've
played many videos of LA's mayor Eric
Garcetti saying nonsense like that and
Lori Lightfoot that Beetlejuice woman in
Chicago like crazy crazy people that
were masking everywhere but somehow they
could bow to protesters without wearing
masks I mean really just crazy stuff so
the point is as information came in he
did the right thing by the way he's not
the only one right Christy gnome up in
South Dakota did the right thing in
Texas they started doing the right thing
in Tennessee they started doing the
right thing Montana et cetera Etc but
the point is everyone gets a little bit
of a leash for the beginning so I don't
I just don't it doesn't strike me that
the covid thing to attack the santis
over covid just does not strike me as a
winning ticket for Trump the other thing
that DeSantis has done incredibly well
is we we went through two years of
burning down cities we went through two
years of virtually every single
mainstream Democrat as cities were
burning saying that they had to defund
the police and that they wanted to
defund the police and we shouldn't be
sending police to domestic squabbles we
should be sending social workers and all
of the crazy stuff and DeSantis said no
enforcement thinking that you can solve
some of these problems through things
like Social Services instead of police
on the street when you have dangerous
people so there's been some experiments
done and and I think it's been really
disastrous in far too many parts of the
country uh but what have we done in the
State of Florida you never saw us to
fund police in the State of Florida not
on my watch
not going to happen not only did you
never see them defund police in the
State of Florida but Miami is now the
safest big city in the United States
despite the fact that we have Miami
Beach here where tons and tons of
college kids and people from all over
the country come to to party all night
long I mean there are people out on the
streets all night and it's still and
every now and again you're going to see
one of those one of those crazy brawls
with a bunch of drunk people leaving a
club but despite all of that we are the
safest big city in the United States and
that and then that culture I mean think
about it we have this unbelievably
biblical basically category five
hurricane wipe out Southwest Florida
I've been down there it's it's
unimaginable the destruction's still and
they're cleaning up fast but it is it is
unbelievable no looting
nobody ran into a Best Buy to steal a
65-inch television nobody uh burned down
the already knocked down Pep Boys no one
was stealing stuff it just was not
happening because what happens is when
you do the right thing and when
leadership is right and your education
systems are right then when when the
hits the fan people don't lose
their minds but if you tell people the
system is evil the system is racist
police are evil damaging property is not
violence Etc et cetera then when there's
a hurricane or a riot or whatever it
might be people will do all of the worst
things and that's why it happens in all
of the blue cities and it did not happen
here at all rather extraordinary the
other thing that uh DeSantis did
incredibly well over the last year
obviously
is that he gave the rights of parents
when it comes to education back to the
parents the school and the Educators and
the superintendents or as they call them
in uh in The Simpsons Super Nintendo
Chalmers uh they do not own your
children you own your children and
nobody should want State Educators
talking about sex or gender privately
with six-year-olds we all know it to be
true the media decided to call it don't
say gay they lied about absolutely
everything and DeSantis just wasn't
having it here's a great moment of him
destroying a reporter by the name of
Evan Donovan on what actually is known
as bill
hb1557 which also by the way has now
been in place here in Florida for months
have they come for the gays guys I've
been busy at work I haven't seen have
they been coming for the gays no anyone
know if they've been coming for the gays
or okay so clip
rights in education what critics called
the don't say gay bill is on the Senate
does it say that in the bill
does it say that in the Bill I'm asking
I'm asking you to tell me what's in the
bill because you are pushing false
narratives it doesn't matter what
critics say it says Advanced classroom
instruction on sexual identity and
gender orientation for who
for grades pre-k through three so
five-year-old six-year-old
seven-year-olds and um the idea that you
wouldn't be honest about that and tell
people what it actually says it's why
people don't trust people like you
because you peddle false narratives and
so we disabuse you of those narratives
and we're going to make sure that
parents are able to send their kid to
kindergarten without having some of this
stuff injected into their school
curriculum
simple truth what's in the bill and then
the journalists don't even know what to
do and that's why they are so angry at
him and we're going to get to in a few
minutes some of how the media is
distorting some of the things that he's
done but I was I just wanted to show you
fact after fact after fact so far what
is actually happening here and guess
what it basically is all good guys it
really is he's engaging in the culture
wars by using the law against woke
ideology and that's what people want you
know for those of us that are are
relatively limited government guys right
and he was part of the freedom caucus
that's you know that's in essence the
most Libertarian caucus that there is in
Congress right he was part of this with
Jim Jordan and a bunch of other guys I
think Thomas Massey a few a few other
guys
um it's not that he's running around
wanting to use the power of the state
he's constantly cutting taxes here right
we've just in the last couple days I
mean they're cutting taxes on gas stoves
like they're doing all sorts of stuff
here it's not that he wants to use the
power of the state but when the culture
keeps encroaching on your family and on
education on your kids and all those
things then he uses the power of the
state and he's using it quite
effectively another way that he's using
it effectively you guys a couple weeks
ago he announced that there will be a
covid-19 panel formed right here in
Florida I was actually at the
announcement a couple weeks ago in Palm
Beach it's going to include obviously
our Surgeon General Joseph latipo who's
absolutely fantastic it's going to
include a Stanford Professor Jay
bhattacharya it's going to include Brett
Weinstein and a whole bunch of other
people and here he is announcing that
and and people are into this because
something is going on with these vaccine
injuries a crisis and so it's not like
this is something that's unprecedented
so today I'm announcing a petition with
the Supreme Court of Florida to impanel
a Statewide grand jury to investigate
any and all wrongdoing in Florida with
respect to covid-19 vaccines and we
anticipate that we will get the approval
for that that will be something that
will be impaneled most likely in the
Tampa Bay area and that will come with
legal processes that will be able to get
more information and to bring legal
accountability for those who committed
misconduct
that's how you lead I mean we're all
feeling something right now I want to
say something about the vaccines uh that
I was thinking about this morning you
know look I'm not vaccinated
David's not vaccinated my guys and gals
in this room are not vaccinated but I
have plenty of loved ones who are
vaccinated
um you don't want anyone to be sick you
don't want to find out that anyone has a
heart condition or whatever it might be
and people had all sorts of awful
pressures applied to them whether they
were going to lose their job or they
weren't going to be able to visit a
loved one or they wanted to leave the
country for what for whatever reason it
might be they guilted people they they
bludgeoned people into doing this thing
and as I always talk about nobody ever
gets fired in the government nobody gets
fired for any of these things you can be
Anthony fauci or Joe Biden and say that
you will not get or transmit covet if
you get vaccinated and nobody gets fired
why wasn't Michelle wilinski who was on
TV the head of the CDC every day
on all the news shows why wasn't she
fired for saying that the covid vaccine
works somebody should be fired fire the
janitor at the building somebody should
pay the price but nobody ever does so
DeSantis is saying okay that's how the
system works we're going to uh have our
grand jury here we're going to start
looking into all of this stuff the buck
stops with me and that's a beautiful
thing I think this is another one
another reason why it's going to be
difficult for Trump to go after DeSantis
on covid because Trump even in the last
week has repeated the same line that he
saved a hundred million lives by
operation warp speed because it got
vaccines into people's arms quicker and
it's like the base hates that man don't
you know that you need to know that your
base hates vaccines they certainly hate
mandates but they hate the vaccines too
and the whole idea that you cut the red
tape which generally speaking people on
the right are for right you don't want a
lot of Regulation because you want
Innovation okay fine but
if you're going to run on
DeSantis screwed up kovid which clearly
isn't true meaning policies related to
lockdowns and things of that nature and
then you're also going to run on that it
was you who got the vaccines out quicker
and now it turns out that the vaccines
aren't working and are actually damaging
People's Health you got a big problem
there and I think he has a couple other
problems when it comes to the base Trump
also really supported Kevin McCarthy I
happen to like Kevin McCarthy and I
think this battle that they went through
is good and McCarthy's showing balls the
base does not seem to like Kevin
McCarthy I think it's on Kevin McCarthy
now to prove that Trump made the wise
move I think that actually could work
out in his benefit but that's something
and I think the other thing is what we
talked about yesterday that Rana
McDaniel is now the head of the RNC
again which the base hates her right
she's an establishment Republican a
niece of Mitt Romney Trump was for so he
has these disconnects with his base
he'll have to figure it out like and you
and also you have to appeal to more
people than your base DeSantis was for
harmie Dylan harmeet who I had on the
show who's an absolutely spectacular
First Amendment lawyer and and I think
it would have been a much better
direction for the Republicans but is
what it is but back to covid for just a
second uh you may have seen this video
it was going viral this is really wild
uh it's from the televised mental
institution known as MSNBC and there is
a host on the network I had never heard
of her before this her name is Yasmin
visigoian and she apparently was not on
air for a couple weeks and then came
back two days ago to explain
why she hasn't been on air and this is
just incredible
I know from my Twitter feed that many of
you have wondered why I have been off
the air for a little while well I have
been dealing with a little bit of a
health scare on December 20th I began to
feel chest pains and they waxed and
waned over a period of 10 days I wasn't
quite sure what to make of it but as
they continued to get worse I started to
think something was actually wrong
it was December 30th when I finally went
to an urgent care and was told I had
reflux I didn't really buy it but I was
relieved it wasn't my heart my body
though was pretty certain not to believe
the reflux the next day on December 30th
I woke up with severe pains both in my
chest and in my left shoulder and it was
like a tightening in my chest when I
took deep breaths that got worse when I
was laying flat
I knew enough at that moment to
understand that it could mean could is
the keyboard here that I was having a
heart attack especially because it was
happening the left part of my shoulder I
want to remind you I run seven miles
three to four times a week where I did
um I do yoga I don't eat meat I don't
smoke I drink occasionally not right now
though because my doctor tells me I
can't aside from probably not getting
enough sleep and working too much I'm a
pretty healthy person but on that day I
was anything but my husband drove me to
the emergency room and from there the
nightmare that has been my January began
I was diagnosed with pericarditis
inflammation of the lining of my heart
brought on by a virus a literal common
cold they determined I had developed
myocarditis inflammation of the actual
heart now the heart muscle
okay first off I wish her well I don't
know who she is I don't wish her ill uh
she is she is twice vaxxed and there she
is having this uh
this admission of what's been going on
with her why she wasn't on air okay
that's fine
um she is claiming that her doctor is
telling her that she got myocarditis and
the lining of the heart that's now
having issues that she got that through
the common cold
have any of you ever heard of this
before kovid
that people who had a common cold
suddenly had these heart issues no you
have not I have not it did not exist
she is twice vaxxed we do know that
especially with young men who are vaxxed
the rates of myocarditis are up
something like 78 and all sorts of heart
problems and you've seen all the videos
of people just dropping dead on soccer
fields and walking down the street and
all this weird stuff
so I cannot speak precisely to her
medical condition but does that not
strike you as the perfect level of
propaganda for MSNBC which is absolutely
100 percent a propaganda Network that
this woman who got twice vaxed does not
link this to the vaccines it somehow is
because of the common cold because if
she was to say you know what my doctor
actually said that this has something to
do with the vaccines or that's the only
X Factor in the equation here I got back
twice we do know that it's causing
myocarditis I now have myocarditis it's
very weird I'm very healthy I run seven
miles all of those things
that would show it would expose the
obvious fraud of everything that goes on
at MSNBC and the New York Times and CNN
and everything else so I thought that
that was worth just just sitting with
that one because I think you're going to
hear more and more of this we're going
to hear more and more stories of people
who have myocarditis or other heart
issues we're going to hear more and more
stories of otherwise healthy people who
are suddenly sick or suddenly getting
you know weird dormant diseases like
shingles or whatever it might be it's
very bizarre and they will not be
blaming it on the backs because then
they'd really have to take that mirror
and look and go man what did I do to
myself what did I do to my family it's
unbelievably horrific we all know people
that are backed it's unbelievably
horrific is what it is but let's get
back to the point of this and the point
of this is that we cannot let anyone
whether it's the media
or Trump or anyone else rewrite history
right because battles are on the way and
I want Trump and DeSantis to to settle
this thing if if this is the direction
where it's going where they're both
going to be running
um but the proof is in the pudding again
of what's going on right here in Florida
so DeSantis didn't just talk about how
we were going to get woke out of the
schools uh in the last couple weeks he's
done a whole bunch on that and uh
anti-woke education reforms are coming
to the free state of Florida
we want to make sure that everybody that
goes through a Florida university has to
take certain core course requirements
that's really focused on giving them the
foundation so that they can think for
themselves and The Core Curriculum must
be grounded in actual history the actual
philosophy that has shaped Western
Civilization
our institutions will be graduating
students I think with degrees that are
going to be meaningful we don't want
students to go through a taxpayer
expense and graduate with a degree in
Zombie studies and so this is going to
make a difference all Dei and CRT
bureaucracies in the State of Florida no
funding and that will Wither on the vine
and I think that that's very important
because it really serves as an
ideological filter a political filter
you've seen different things I mean new
college has really embraced that and
that's part of the reason I think it
hasn't been successful in the enrollment
down so much because I think people want
to see true academics and they want to
get rid of some of the political window
dressing that seems to accompany all
this so that's no longer going to be in
the State of Florida the most important
we brought accountability for tenured
faculty now all tenured faculty at our
state universities must undergo review
every five years and can be let go if
they are not performing tax so the
beauty of that clip is he's not just
saying he's going to do these things
he's actually doing it you know new
College which is on the west coast of
Florida became one of the wokest schools
in the nation it was going the road of
all the Ivy League schools it was going
the road of Evergreen State where Brett
Weinstein was and they went in and now
I'm going to show you a video of Chris
Ruffo in a moment you know Chris Ruffo
he's been on the show many times from
the Manhattan Institute he's been one of
the great intellectual leaders of the
anti-wolf campaign he is now going to be
on the board at that school and they are
bringing in people who are going to get
rid of die diversity inclusion and
equity and get rid of all the woke stuff
and this is and all it's going to do to
get us to that first clip from Bill
Maher is revert us back to where where
we thought we were five years ago maybe
we weren't quite there that none of this
nonsense existed obviously some of it
did but nobody wants nobody's sane
except and it's just the woke crazy
lefties that want this and they're media
allies want literally the people in
charge of college admissions to be like
okay we have all these people here they
have roughly the same grades let's get
the black guy let's get the trans girl
let's get the one with the limp and the
lazy eye like nobody wants that nobody
wants that except the new neo-racists of
the Democrat Party of the left and of
the machine uh so Chris Ruffo who I just
mentioned he is working with Governor
DeSantis on this he is not a Floridian
but he is helping Florida because he
will go to where his work can uh can be
fertilized basically or where his his
work is the fertilizer for a growing
Freedom country we are our own country
here basically here's rufo right after
this at this this is a day or two
talking about how they're getting woke
out of not only of new college in
Florida but the entire system here
the bureaucrats
feel like they run the show they feel
like they're in charge they feel like
they're the authorities and just by
exposing what they're doing they feel
like the the public is intruding
that's not how it's supposed to work
these are public institutions supported
by taxpayers and they're governed by the
legislature they're governed by the
public officials and so what I think is
really important here you have an
ideology of diversity versus ideology of
equality treating people equally we can
have that philosophical debate and we
should because most people once they
understand what's happening would oppose
this Dei ideology but the deeper context
and the deeper importance of this
initiative it's reestablishing public
control and public authority over the
public universities and so look you can
have two different kinds of people you
can have rule by the bureaucracy or rule
by the people and in many states they've
opted for the former but in Florida with
this bold initiative the governor and
the legislators are saying no no no we
see the problem we're understanding the
problem we're going to re-establish the
rule of the people over our institutions
man I got to tell you Florida basically
if America is going to continue as a
nation and I suppose there is an if
there uh Florida is 30 years in the
future this is the blueprint this is the
model get rid of this stuff just don't
complain about it and let it take down
your institutions and take down your
families and have your sons think their
daughters and everything else go for it
destroy it we're doing it right here so
how does the media treat this when all
they're trying to do is get us back to
equality get us back to not looking at
everybody by their race or their gender
or their sexuality right treat everyone
equally and as desanta said give them
the skills imagine going to college
where you would learn the skills of how
to be a functional person where you
would learn an honest assessment of
History where you might learn some basic
economics the tools then to go out into
the world as a 21 year old let's say and
have some basic knowledge of how to
function in in the society wouldn't that
be good rather than learning lesbian
badminton it probably would but listen
to how the mainstream media treats
Florida and governor governor DeSantis
as he's going ahead and doing these
things here is Don Lemon from CNN
thank you this is thank you Papi this is
bizarre I know
I know what are we doing here I mean
this I feel like we're going back I feel
like I'm watching a bad version of like
Pleasantville where you're I I don't get
what's happening it feels like the 1950s
all over again with like book Banning
this is this is cancel culture from
people who are I guess they just want
our kids to be ignorant and to control
the teachers it is this is outrageous I
I don't I really don't even know how to
explain what's going on here it's just
Don Lemon is a complete and utter
buffoon propagandist liar he
either has no idea what he's talking
about in which case he should be fired
and that's not cancel culture you are
you should be fired when you are
completely incompetent at what you do
right if you dig holes for pools and you
can't do that right you should be fired
if you whatever it is that you do if you
don't do it well you should be fired
that's not cancel culture so he either
has no idea what he's talking about or
he is a complete liar and and
propagandist the book that he's
referring to is a book called
genderqueer which was going into
elementary schools we're talking about
second and third grade it was literally
showing body parts and talking to kids
about how to give hand jobs so if you
think that should be in schools then you
should be hanging out with Don Lemon
that is what they were Banning nobody
thinks it should be there no one's
Banning the books as if the books can't
be published but they should not be in
public schools we all know that but
that's why they never mention the title
of the book or the content of the book
he just tries to make it like it's
hysteria and this is book burning as if
it's 1934 Nazi Germany it's completely
insane but Don Lemon is completely
insane he is awoke leftist who has been
completely broke and once you are
completely broke through woke you make
everything about race here he is talking
to New York City mayor Eric Adams about
the death of Tyree Nichols now Tyree
Nichols is the black man
who by every estimation was just
unjustly killed by five black police
officers they were all black there were
no whities involved in this thing no
honkies okay uh but of course when five
black officers kill a black man it has
to be of course racism here's Don Lemon
okay well let me ask you the chief CJ
day this one in my interview with her
she said that all the officers being
black it takes race off the table do you
agree with that
uh no no I don't uh I think that I
understand what uh the chief was saying
and I think she uh really handled this
situation in a very professional Way She
Moves swiftly she assured that those
officers were removed from the
Department she took all the necessary
steps uh but I think a race is still on
the table uh when a culture of policing
historically has treated those from
different groups differently uh even
when the individuals are from that same
group that culture can still exist and
we have to zero in on it being honest
about it and making sure that we
properly train police for the realities
of the cities that they are policing do
you realize how crazy this is uh there
you have Eric Adams who happens to be
black and Don Lemon who happens to be
black I don't care that either one of
them are black I really don't
um and I generally don't care about the
color of police officers or and I don't
care about the color of the perpetrators
if you break the law if you're
threatening people all those things it
has to be dealt with now this is this by
again every estimate is a completely
unjust killing what they did was
horrible but if you think that five
black police officers were acting with
racism in their heart as they as they
killed this black guy then then racism
has no meaning whatsoever
black people are the biggest anti-black
racist like what are we actually saying
here but this was the danger of the woke
and this is why you must get woke out of
schools because once it has permeated
all of the institutions once you have
taught a generation of young people to
think everything is about gender and
race and those immutable characteristics
you can get them to believe any crazy
that you want cue Whoopi
Goldberg in The View
but you know
when will the brutality finally lead to
some police reform from the ground up
because
clearly it doesn't matter if it's a
white policeman or a black policeman it
is a problem in the police and the
policing itself you know seems things
don't seem to make sense to people
unless it's somebody they can feel or
they can recognize but how many times do
we have to do we need to see white
people also get beaten before anybody
will do anything I'm not suggesting that
so don't write us and tell me what a you
know what a racist I am I'm not
suggesting it I just said it
but I'm not suggesting it that would be
a completely other thing than by me
saying it the way I just said it that
wouldn't be a suggestion that was just a
sentence
now first off this incident uh was in
Memphis by the way and again it was five
black officers but because they have
combined the idea of policing to race
they have to convince you that the black
officers who killed the black man did it
in the name of white supremacy it is
complete nonsense but now to link that
story to everything else that I've done
here today they continued on The View to
blame the death of Tyree Nichols
yes I mean this is so just bananas they
did tie it to Ron desantis's education
reform and remember this happened in
Memphis it was all black guys who killed
a black guy Ron DeSantis is the governor
of Florida but watched the magic trick
and what we saw in this case is that
good cops come in any gender any class
any color and bad cops can be of any
gender and any color and these cops were
blue before they were black this is why
we cannot ban history this is why why
tell your guy we need to learn tell him
this is why in the midst of all of this
happening Banning AP African-American
studies in Florida is the wrong thing to
do because we need to learn from history
clearly it doesn't matter if it's a
white policeman or a black policeman it
is a problem in the police and the
policing itself you know seems things
don't seem to make sense to people
unless it's somebody they can feel or
they can recognize but how many times do
we have to do we need to see white
people also get beaten before anybody
will do anything I'm not suggesting that
so don't write us and tell me what a you
know what a racist I am I'm just asking
is that is that what people have to see
in order to wake up and realize this
affects us all
okay so we had to show you the whoopee
thing again you know what's so
interesting if you listen to what Eric
Adams said in the previous clip he's
very impressed with the way they're
dealing with all of this stuff so that
that sort of puts Whoopi's Point down
right there it's like they're they're no
one's defending the there's literally
nobody out there I I have not seen one
person I kid you not not one person on
crazy Twitter defending what the police
officers did here but again this jump to
it's about racism and then to link that
to DeSantis and the and the Banning of
this AP African-American history course
the course was going to teach gender
queer theory in connection right because
they love intersectionality they love
the idea of taking all of these
perceived oppressions and then combining
them into one super voltron-like uh uh
oppression and no
AP African-American history you now we
could have an argument about whether
that should be a course in the first
place whether we should just have
American history and of course we should
teach an honest assessment of slavery
and the civil rights movement and
everything else but it had nothing to do
with that that is not why Ron DeSantis
banned it he banned it because they were
putting gender queer theory in there
they were putting this insane
sexualization of everything in there
they were tagging it and combining it
with reparations and a whole bunch more
it was not an education course it was an
indoctrination course but they tie
somehow this Police Murder uh in Memphis
to the governor of Florida and of course
they have to keep going because they
know who the threat is and the threat to
their hysterical I would argue racist
world view uh well it used to be this it
used to be Trump but now it's DeSantis
so we got to combine those guys too
uh some of these other Republican
candidates give Trump people an off-ramp
they can actually leave the chaos and
they still don't take it like well we
don't sense all the other beliefs that
they say here's the thing to keep in
mind Ron DeSantis is now running a state
where he decides what can be taught yeah
schools or not so you know the off ramp
is like I'm not sure it's an off ramp it
really has to do I'm not sure well not
because you got a lot of racism going on
and a little bit of an insanity I mean
God fearing on which one I mean that's
the thing I have to say I really have
sympathy to some degree to to the
average woman who is raising two kids
um who's at home cleaning the house and
has that show on in the background and
then they are completely brainwashed NPC
they watch that show and they hear
what's her name Anna Navarro talk about
how Rhonda Santos is Banning AP
African-American history they give no
context to it they don't mention the
gender queer thing so the average woman
watching that show who maybe is somewhat
apolitical she watches that and she goes
well Ron DeSantis must be sort of racist
because he's Banning African-American
studies then Whoopi continues with that
and then she watches all that stuff and
she hears it and she thinks it's fact
they don't explain anything or that Ron
DeSantis is deciding what books you can
read you know what actually California
is Banning books they're banning books
like Huck Finn because of the n-word a
Huck Finn which is an incredible novel
that everyone that every kid should read
every every eighth grader probably
should read Huck Finn
um so they're the ones actually
rewriting history
um but but by the way to say that he
decides what can be taught well someone
has to decide what's taught in schools
and I would much rather leave that
honestly to Ron DeSantis than to Whoopi
Goldberg or Gavin Newsom or anything
else but to go back to the to the woman
watching this show if you want to know
why so much is screwed up
in our country at the national level
right now so the view which is on right
now thank God you're watching this
instead of the view
um there's a certain amount of people
that watch it it's basically I think
it's still the number one show in
daytime so you have all these women it's
mostly middle it's you know it's sort of
youngish to middle-aged women with
families watching us their husbands are
at working out working there at home
watching this show and they hear all
this propaganda and they're told that
Rhonda said to say it's black people and
Republicans only care about money and
Democrats care about people and all of
that factory setting nonsense then their
husband comes home and the husband
probably went to work the husband's
probably not thrilled to pay a ton in
taxes blah blah blah and you know what
happens the wife starts saying these
things and maybe the husband knows a
little more of the reality well actually
um and this obviously is not the most
perfect
one-size-fits all metaphor for everybody
but I think this is a huge chunk of
people so you have these women that have
sort of become hysterical related to all
of this stuff because of pure propaganda
they flip between watching The View and
the lies of the view and then they turn
on CNN and Don Lemon saying this is
1950s America again in this nonsense and
then the husband comes home and he
worked all day and he just wants a
little piece in the house and you know
what he might want at the end of the day
can I say I think guys still
allowed to want he might want a
so he might not want to fight
with her and show her and show her
actually it's not true it's not true
what they're saying about Ryan DeSantis
and an AP African-American studies
course should have nothing to do with uh
queer Theory but you know what at the
end of the day he doesn't do it he
doesn't do it and she votes that way and
then he probably has to hide which way
he votes because he wants a and
you can't blame him for wanting a
quite frankly let's continue
how do I segue out of this one let's see
what I can do here
um speaking of blow jobs
um
Republicans speaking of black this isn't
going to be good it's tacky it's tacky
let's just do a let's just do a reset
here let's just
wash our hands of and move on
uh it does turn out that there's no way
I can do it there's no way I can do it
look Nikki Haley's running for president
okay and I apologize to Nikki for that
that transition there it just I just got
out of control there was nothing I could
do it's a live show you know what I mean
Mickey Haley is going to run for
president uh we've got some info from
Fox News on that former South Carolina
Governor Nikki Haley who served as
ambassador to the United Nations during
former president Donald Trump's
Administration will join Trump in the
race for 2024 Republican Presidential
nomination multiple sources confirmed to
Fox News digital that Haley will
formally declare her candidacy for the
White House at an event in Charleston
South Carolina on February 15th with an
invitation soon going out to her
supporters news of Haley's announcement
was first reported by the Post and
Courier newspaper in South Carolina now
the reason that I'm mentioning that of
course Trump referenced it up top when
he was talking about Nikki Haley
potentially running and then he had that
little shot at DeSantis the reason I'm
reiterating this is that I think it is
good to have more voices I think the
fighting is good I think some degree of
the of the Trump DeSantis thing could be
good for both of them right like like if
it ends up being Trump maybe going
through DeSantis if he ends up running
will have sharpened the way he's going
to do policy
and for DeSantis maybe having to get
through Trump will sharpen the way he
debates or how he fights back or
something like that Nikki Haley I happen
to like her it seems like the the bass
bass doesn't love her but the bass is
sort of all over the place right now the
base is anti-vaccine and Trump is for a
vaccine so like there's a huge amount of
swirling craziness right now but I think
more voices in this right now could be
really really great the Democrats have
become a hysterical monolith that
everyone must fall in line with right
the Republicans have a great opportunity
to to maybe not all destroy each other
wouldn't that be something if there's 10
people up there if you've got Trump and
DeSantis and Nikki Haley and maybe you
get Tim Scott and who knows Ted Cruz or
Rand Paul or a couple other guys you get
a big businessman something else you get
this whole crop of people and they get
up there and maybe they don't go for
mutually assured destruction
and they go man we got a much bigger
enemy I think my vision's the best but
we're not going to all destroy each
other I think that the real Challenge on
that will be left up to Trump he will
have to decide what he wants to do on
the destruction phase and and we shall
see we shall see so that's my feelings
about all that I hope you will stick
around for the locals post game show
which you can join us at
reubenreport.locals.com uh oh and I can
confirm that as of uh like a minute
before the show I got a text from our
guy who handles our back end stuff and
he has told me that January it's not the
January is just our best month ever it
like we I think we doubled by like 64
from our previous best month ever like
everything's working it's blowing up
it's all good uh head on over to locals
right now we leave you with uh what I'm
told is very accurate uh video from the
Paul Pelosi arrest and I'm told this is
completely unedited and this is exactly
what happened and I'll see you on the
other side
he's going today
[Laughter]
[Music]
in God we must sir please get out of the
vehicle you have a great night
sir huh please get out of the vehicle
you know what absolutely and thank you
for doing your job I appreciate it
also thank you for releasing me upon my
own recognizance sir have you been
drinking yes I have I've had five or six
small batch Bourbons that's a lot I'm
gonna have to ask you to take a
breathalyzer test
got a runner stop running
[Music]